SuperMario question box candy and a
blow-up doll for your dog it's episode 7
of loot you can watch Vsauce 2 like a
pro with this stainless steel Mouse
even though real men use hand forged
carbon steel but play it safe with this
sexy chainmail vest suggested by shark
Chan on facebook.com slash Vsauce game
you can submit your own work there or if
you prefer walk around in some Beauty
pain shoes these were also submitted a
Vsauce and even though they're not for
sale they're cool you can mix up a
cocktail like a culture jammer with a
spray paint can shaker and then while in
by beam strain your eyes with Yanko
designs white on white or black on black
playing cards and look even fancier with
their collar stays they keep your
collars sharp but can also screw cut and
open a brewski ditch the integers and
tell time like a winner with values like
nine point four eight two point three
point five seven seven or 3.14 also
available as a necklace Luna and curious
sells tights covered in water drops
ferns or your guts dripping down your
legs but don't worry boys there are
mantyhose for you take photos of your
sexy man tights with this lego camera
and then protect the pictures inside USB
jewelry break time let's cool down with
some ice cream made out of human breast
milk speaking of which if you're unhappy
with your natural ones buy some fake but
more noticeable nipples just be sure to
protect them with this cross nipple
shield to mature for you where some
Barbie doll part jewelry instead and
then curl up with your favorite book
like a rat dissection manual or the more
useful original roadkill cookbook you
could store them on this optical
illusion bookshelf or read them as
ebooks in your hot tub using a $3
waterproof Kindle cover ziploc bag if
it's not hot enough warm up with cubist
literatures scarf slowly even then give
a toast to protecting your table tops
with toast coasters that 19 takes it a
step further with a choo-choo train that
deconstructs into a complete dining set
which is great for kids or for awesome
adults who eat stuffed hamburgers
made with this epic press handle the hot
plates like a pixelated chef or study
typography with this great type Anatomy
chart so you can master links lobes and
tittles add a joystick to your iPad or
some goat milk Cologne
to your dog now it's time for something
free flux sets your monitors colors to
match the type of sunlight your body
expects at any hour you use it it's free
for PC Mac and Linux and saves your eyes
I leave you now with my favorite
t-shirts let me know in the comments
below what you wish you had on a t-shirt
who knows maybe we'll make them for you
more importantly make sure you're
subscribed to Vsauce 2 and more
importantly still as always thanks for
watching
[Music]